welcome to the city of the future
a smart city that knows everything about
you from how you like your coffee
to whether you've broken the law or even
if you've grown a beard
sound farfetched while the smart city
we're about to tour doesn't exist yet
all of the parts do they're all
components of real projects happening
all over the world put them together and
this is what life may well be like in
the not too distant future
you go to work your office building
knows exactly who's coming and going
and what they need thanks to thousands
of inbuilt sensors collecting data
the energy efficient building is
designed for your comfort reacting to
changes in the weather
and the number of people in the building
and adjusting its climate accordingly
wherever you sit the lighting will
adjust to suit your preferences
the building will even recall your
regular coffee order and there's no
chance of it getting your name wrong
on your way home you pass lamp posts
laden with sensors and hd cameras
that monitor and record the world around
them 24 7.
air quality and traffic flow data tell
you the quickest and cleanest route
and alert emergency services to
accidents
you arrive home to a nutritious meal
made from locally grown avocados using
hydroponics
so no need for soil sensors allow urban
farmers to make constant adjustments to
temperature
light and water and monitor the plants
responses so it's easier
and cheaper to grow fresh food in cities
the level of control smart technology
gives can also be used to make food
tastier
in singapore they've already found a way
to make kale sweeter and softer
so even the fussiest of eaters will
enjoy their greens
your health is flourishing thanks to
your perfectly balanced diet
but you also regularly update your
doctors using data sent directly from
your smart watch
they analyze it and prescribe
personalized drugs and supplements that
are quickly 3d printed
just for you your baby
stirs and you're alerted by a smart
blanket reassured that all is well
child mortality rates are at an all-time
low you go to bed but the sensors in the
street
never sleeps they're busy policing
anti-social behavior
identifying people smoking in
unauthorized zones
or throwing rubbish from high-rise
buildings crime rates are negligible
while much of this might sound pretty
idyllic it is not without issues
smart cities go hand in hand with
gathering and storing
huge amounts of personal data and using
it to control city life
for governments keen to control certain
populations this is an incredibly
powerful tool
every moment of your daily routine can
be tracked anyone with access to this
data
can find out where you live where you go
every day the places you visit at night
and who you're with this data can be
used by people with
far more nefarious aims than making you
the perfect soya latte
you could leave your phone at home but
with advanced facial recognition cctv in
the mix
authorities can easily keep tabs on you
in places like xinjiang in china
where growing a beard can already get
you reported this is a frightening
prospect
so are the benefits of a smart city
worth giving up privacy and freedom for
can governments and corporations be
trusted with such huge data sets on all
of us
what happens if there's a mistake in the
system or you want to overthrow the
system itself
whether you think smart technology means
we're sleepwalking into a dystopian
future
or enabling us to live a vastly more
convenient and sustainable lifestyle
it's coming soon to a city near you
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video